- [Voiceover] You are graphing rectangle
ABCD in the coordinate plane.
The following are three of
the vertices of the rectangle.
They give us the coordinates.
What are the coordinates of point D?
Alright, well a good place to start,
let's just plot these, the three
vertices that they give us.
So it looks like they're
on the first quadrant, so
I'm going to focus my coordinate
axes on the first quadrant.
So that's going to be my y-axis.
And let me now, this is
going to be my x-axis.
And let's see.
The highest x value that I have,
I have a two, I have
a five, I have a five,
it looks like it goes up to five.
So I could say one,
two, three, four, and five.
So that's five, I can just do
one, two, three, four, and five.
Let's see, the highest y value,
I have one, one, and a six.
It goes up to six.
So one, two, three,
four, five, and six.
I can number them.
One, two three, four, five, and six.
Now let's plot the points.
So let's first point A,
which is at two comma one.
X equals two, y is equal to one.
So that's that point right over there.
Now let's plot point B.
Point B is at five comma one.
So x equals five, y is equal to one.
That's right over there.
Now let's plot point C.
Point C, maybe I need to
find another color here.
Point C is at x is equal
to five, y is equal to six.
X is equal to five, y is equal to six.
So that sticks us
roughly right over there.
And so we need to figure
out what D is going to be.
Well D is going,
this is a rectangle.
The sides are parallel, all the vertices,
we have right angles at all the vertices.
So point D is going to
have the same x coordinate
as this point right over here.
So this is going to have
the same x coordinate.
So it's going to have an x
coordinate, so let me write this.
D is going to have an x coordinate of two.
And it's going to have
the same y coordinate
as this point up here.
So it's going to have
a y coordinate of six.
Of six.
So D is going to be at
the point two comma six.
And you see when we do that,
we have set up a nice rectangle here.
We can draw the rectangle,
so that's one side, that's the top side,
that's another side, another side.
And then we have that just like that.
There you go, we have our rectangle,
but most importantly we
answered our question,
what are the coordinates
of point D. Alright.